c'est l'histoire d'une famille en chasse
dans un hôtel particulier du 16e siècle
une famille désormais représentée par un
trio formé par des chefs triplement
étoilé didier clément arrive dans sa
belle famille il a 24 ans le chef
s'inscrit dans une filiation une
continuité à 63 ans dont 50 étoiles et
il ne perd pas le nord
l'homme reste stoïque pense avoir une
identité une démarche donc je vais pas
demain pour faire plaisir à untel ou
untel venir maintenant la ccl puisqu'il
faut faire ça vient je leur ai vendu mon
âme au diable ou ou perdu voilà mais mes
repères j'ai pas l'intention de
retourner ma veste
le couple clément et complémentaires
voire fusionnelle l'histoire de cet
établissement
ils la portent à bout de bras et
l'écrivent à quatre mains c'est vraiment
une inspiration commune un échange
commun nous promenons ensemble dans la
forêt on va sentir des odeurs sur notre
passage des odeurs par exemple de murs
demande sauvage de mousse ça va voilà on
se regarde
il ya une complicité et le soir didier
va improviser un bouillon qui va servir
par exemple on amuse bouche qui va
reproduire ces odeurs lie ses parfums là
l'héritière c'est hélène clément fille
unique partagée entre paris sa société
de communication et romorantin le
creuset familial
moi je suis la nouvelle génération en
pleine transmission je suis en train
d'apprendre le métier de mes deux
parents a dirigé une maison c'est avoir
une vision générale de la maison
et faire en sorte que tout fonctionne
bien c'est bientôt l'heure du coup de
cuisine chacun est à son ouvrage car
nous sommes de rochers et biches 3
assortiment